"﻿They walked past Baker's Pond..."
For the past 10 years, Family Literacy Day has been held across the country...
...to help students learn together in a variety of ways.
It helps to promote that critical thinking and reading...
...that's so important for everyday life.
Literacy is a lifelong lesson that affects every area of a person's life...
...including health, economic status and employment.
Without strong literacy skills, I'd have a hard time doing my job.
Experts admit not every child is anxious to read.
Teachers like Tina Castro say the key is finding a topic they're interested in learning about.
We try to provide reading material at a variety of levels...
...to make them feel comfortable and to get them reading more.
Experts say just 20 minutes a day is all it takes to make an improvement.
Anything like picking up a storybook, spending time with your children,...
...helping them read and getting them to read to you...
...makes the difference when it comes to literacy levels.
Students from kindergarten to Grade 8 at this school are encouraged to read every day.
So what do they reach for when they want to curl up with a good book?
"The Outsiders," it's an old book but I really enjoy it.
Harry Potter, Eragon, all the series with magic.
Whether it's a classic novel or a popular series,...
...the goal among educators and caregivers is to cast a reading spell on children,...
...getting them hooked on books and the earlier the better.